the main difference with this variant is
that it is
up to 70 percent more transmissible that
is
quite staggering when you consider you
have a
a virus which we already know
is easily transmitted from people to
people you have a variant which has been
identified which makes it even more
transmissible and that really does worry
the government scientists and that's why
we've had
this announcement from the prime
minister today they're
talking about the virus affecting
the r number and the ability
for it to spread so quickly that it will
affect
that r8 that our number that we've been
talking about all throughout the year by
up to 0.4 i think was the the number
uh chris um
[Music]
patrick valance used the the csa when he
was talking about it lots of detail
about the protein structure
of the virus itself which in it for us
that doesn't really
matter the scientists will have a look
at the way that this virus is mutating
and changing what really matters
is how quickly it is spreading from
people to people
and we were given this assurance right
at the beginning that it
it's not making people any more sick
it's not
making people die any quicker but if
in effect what you do is you plot the
timeline if people are becoming more
infected
invariably they will end up becoming
sick they will end up going to hospital
and that puts pressure on the hospitals
and then people will die and and it's a
numbers game
as far as the scientists are concerned
but for all of us
it's having an impact on our lives and
what they were talking about is
it has now become the dominant strain
this
this new variant is now the dominant
strain in london and the south
east and it is although in some small
measure
in other parts of the country that's why
wales has made these announcements today
it says it's identified this new variant
in wells
it hasn't really spread to the rest of
the country and it's not having the same
effect
on the rest of the country as it is in
london and the south
east and that's why we've had this tier
four
ban on traveling out of the capital some
people might argue
it's too late because most people might
have decided
ahead of the first christmas week over
the last christmas weekend
to leave the capital and leave the
southeast and go and visit friends
and relatives and loved ones in other
parts of the country but that's
what they were saying they were saying
look at where it's spreading in london
and southeast where it is now the
dominant strain
and where it isn't in other parts of the
country we want people to stop
spreading it because if it spreads it
takes seed in
uh chris whitty's own words and then we
have a real problem then people become
infected much more quickly than they
have done during the year
and that creates more pressure on the
nhs people
become infected invariably they fall
sick and some people need hospital
treatment
and people will start dying as well so a
real worry for the government this new
variance